I'll show you my implementation first
off i'm using date now and i'm storing
it to date submitted in this object
literal this is what becomes our note by
the way in case you're interested that
number is the number of milliseconds
since january first nineteen seventy fun
fact well anyway this is simple enough
I'm just storing our current time into
the date submitted property now I've
also added something down here in the
view down here in the view I've added a
little piece of functionality to the
render function when render is called
the date gets put into the HTML string
now a little note about this thing here
I'm actually making a new date with that
number and then I'm converting it to a
string that ends up looking something
like this now it's not the most
beautiful readable date but you can go
in and use some of the date methods to
make it better if you'd like but the
coolest thing is if you look back the
amount of code hasn't really changed
much at all we just have this one new
line in the view and this one new line
here where we create our notes now one
quick side note about this being in the
octopus strictly speaking you could make
the argument that this is kind of data
ish maybe it should be in the model and
that's a totally legitimate argument in
fact a lot of organizational paradigms
and frameworks put this kind of a thing
in the model itself now for simplicity
in this particular example I'm not doing
that I'm just creating an object literal
right here but later on in the course
you'll see some of the interesting and
slightly more complicated ways that
people form models